- Gary V.
The biggest confusion in America in 2019
is that money is happiness,
and I want people to be happy.
(audience cheering)
(soft music)
My friends, until our
society redefines success
in being happy not being rich,
everybody will continue
to go down the path
that we're seeing in our society
of depression, anxiety, drugs.
(audience clapping)
If, for some way, through
a joke, or an analogy
or a conversation here today
or answer to a question,
I can get you to start the process
of genuinely being able to handle judgment
because you finally are exhausted.
Exhausted of living your life
based on other people's opinions.
You don't do things because
somebody says you're ugly
or you're stupid in a comment
and you have no idea who they are
and they're hiding between an avatar
and some bullshit name over here
all the way to your mom.
That.
That's what I spend all my time on.
From this person to that person.
Why is that dictating you?
They think they're doing the right thing
'cause they fucking
actually love their parents.
I get it.
I love my parents so
uncomfortably much it scares me.
But they live it because they're appeasing
lawyer, two kids, living in
this area, doing this job,
don't take risks 'cause
we told you not to.
We came from a generation that
didn't so you're doing that.
Or I was once an entrepreneur
and fucked it up,
and so we were scared,
so now you don't do that.
They live for their parents.
They think it's good
'cause everything's good
'cause you're doing
what your parents want.
You feel like it's good.
Then what starts happening is they start
to resent their parents
because now they're popping
to their 50th birthday,
their 60th birthday,
their 65th birthday.
They get a health scare and they're like,
"Fuck, I'm not doing
what I wanna be doing."
The question is why?
Like, I'm just trying to get to why.
Like, who?
My friends, every person in here
that's not 100% happy, including myself,
is not doing something because
of judgment of somebody else.
You have to be honest with yourself
'cause if you're incapable of that,
you have no prayer of happiness.
And being honest with yourself is hard.
It's not fun to say you suck.
Vulnerability is strength.
If you took a step back and actually said,
"What do I fucking like?"
I'm trying to get people to win.
I'm watching real deep sadness
and it's not because of social media.
Social media is not making you sad.
Your insecurity's making you sad.
(audience cheering and clapping)
- [Man] I love you, Gary!
- I love you back.
My friends, this is a fucking game.
You wanna fucking win in life?
Fall in love with losing
because most people here are scared of it.
The number one unlock to
happiness in this room
is to go out there after this talk
and get naked about your vulnerabilities,
what you suck at, take
a step back, go humble.
This is about losing and
humility at the forefront,
and nobody's talking about it.
There's no system.
You wanna build something?
It's hard work and talent.
(audience cheering and clapping)
Hard work and talent.
I know what's gonna happen.
This is gonna post on YouTube
and I'm gonna read the comments.
They'll be like,
"Yo, easy for him to say 'I'm rich'
"but I'll cry in my Ferrari."
Until you're crying in your Ferrari.
And when you have money
and you're sad as fuck,
real bad shit happens
'cause that shit goes
from Cognac and weed
to cocaine and guns in your fucking mouth.
My friends, it is time, once and for all,
to fucking cut the bullshit.
We need to start talking about happiness.
(audience cheering and clapping)
By the way, I think I should
only talk in New Jersey.
- [Man] I agree.
- Right?
Fuck it.
(audience cheering)
I'm not sure I wanna talk anywhere else
but fucking New Jersey.
(audience cheering and clapping)
I fucking love you guys.
On some real shit.
I fucking love you guys on some real shit!
Fuck.
Please take my energy here
today 'cause it's on rare form
to get happy.
Just get happy, yo.
(chuckling)
Fuck.
Like, fuck.
(soft piano music)